Usted junto a otros diputados afines a
Castillo denuncian que lejos de lo que
se ha denominado un autogolpe, ha habido un complot
contra el expresidente. ¿Por qué
creen que ha habido este complot?
Buenos días, muy buenas tardes a todos, gracias
por la invitación. Bueno, desde inicio del
Gobierno, la derecha acusó al señor Castillo de
terrorista, luego, que iba a expropiar las propiedades, luego que
iba a estatizar a las empresas, que violó a
su hija y todas las acusaciones sin ningún
video, sin ningún audio, sin una prueba. Y ya los
medios con una actitud abusiva lo condenaban a
actos delincuenciales que hasta ahora no se
han probado. Y medios peruanos han sacado a
la luz chats internos que parecen indicar que
la expresidenta del Consejo de Ministros, Betsy
Chávez, conocía lo que iba a pasar. Señor Kamiche,
¿tienen pruebas de que parte del Ejecutivo haya
inducido o coaccionado de alguna forma a
Castillo a decretar el cierre del Congreso?
Hasta donde yo sé, no hay ninguna prueba
de que haya sido inducido a esto.
Yo, en mi concepto personal, veo que el señor Castillo
en un afán de querer salir
de esta crisis, de este abuso de poder,
tomó una decisión que ya hemos visto a la consecuencias.
Yde ser ciertas las acusaciones y más allá de la
reprobación ética o las hipotéticas responsabilidades jurídicas
de las personas a quienes se acusan de este complot,
¿eximiría estoa Pedro Castillo de las acusaciones de rebelión?
Debe de investigarse todo. La corrupción en el país nos genera pérdidas,
de seis mil millones de dólares al año.
Y se debe investigar, caiga quien caiga. A mí lo que me asombra
es,si queremos eliminar la corrupción,
por qué no se habla de la extradición de Hinostroza y de Toledo
que le han hecho tanto daño a Perú